[Music]
hello my name is Newan Fam I'm a Staff
scientist at the Princess Margaret
Cancer Center I manag the uh Princess
Margaret living B Bank the PDX core and
today I'd like to share with you some of
our work using the PDX PDO uh patient
derived tumor models to better
understand tumor heterogenity and Drug
sensitivity and response um and
adaptation of the
tumors I have no potential conflict to
disclose um I like to address the
learning objectives of what these models
are how we use them and where can we
access these
models I also like to emphasize the
importance of generating models that
reflect the disease spectrum and I
describe the use of these models in our
non-s small cell lung cancer research
program um that's led by Dr Ming sanchow
and Jeffrey Lou at the Princess Margaret
cancer
center and also I like to describe how
these models can be made into renewable
resources that are that is of high
quality for for Reliable use um by resar
Searchers as you know cancer treatment
um the most Curative um treatment is by
surgery if the cancer diagnosed at early
stage but for most cancer types
depending on cancer type there are
various uh systemic standard cytotoxic
chemotherapy and radiotherapy and also
um there are cancer
biomarker uh specific therapies um we
call them targeted therapies and also
immunotherapy
thies so how can we use um the patient
derived models to study the clinical CH
challenges and treatment of cancers
because most cancers are detected at at
Advanced stage where surgery um um
treatment is not possible the treatments
stop working and Cancers are without
actionable Gene alterations meaning
there are no um targeted therapy
available so I would describe the
context of the clinical challenges and
the use of these models in the in the um
study of non-s small cell lung
cancer as you can see here um lung
cancer is um diagnosed um at early and
late stage of disease after surgery 30%
of the patients do relapse and in most
cases lung cancer is detected in later
stages
lung cancer is also uh classified into
the histotypes the major hyot types are
the non-sm small cell 80% and the small
cell here we will focus today on the um
major subtype of non-s small cell the
adino uh carcinoma called luad for short
and they are further classified into
genotype classifications for um targeted
therapy when possible in reality we know
that targeted therapy even though they
are primarily um identified through one
driver oncogene uh in which the
alteration increases signaling and
dependence of cancer survival and the
targeted therapy inhibits the cing
activity and thereby causing um fast
response to the therapy in reality these
tumors are actually classified by a
group of variants and potentially these
unique set will impact on treatment
response and
outcomes we can appreciate these in such
studies of population uh tumor profiling
databases here we have the cancer genome
Atlas project where the Consortium uh
profile
11,000 tumor patients tumors from
patients uh representing 33 tumor types
and 10 rare cancer
ERS as we can see here by report by
Bailey and team um in studying these 33
tumor types do these variants impact on
treatment here we can see treatment as
categorized as approved standard of care
therapies the F FDA approved
therapies um in clinical trials and pre
preclinical research so the first cancer
here is the skin cutaneous melanoma and
you can see the other canc cancer with
the high approved uh standard care
therapy targeted therapy is the thyroid
cancer um six columns across now those
two cancers are characterized by
dominant mutations uh for most of the
tumors um whereas the other cancer types
you'll see that um there are no um
targeted therapies approved and the
variants are still being investigated
for um therapeutic impact in clinical
Tri or preclinical cancer research here
I've also highlighted down there the
lung adinal carcinoma which is the focus
of today and the other major subtype as
you know is squis further along there on
the bar chart where there's no approv
therapy back to the lung adinal
carcinoma we see about 10% or just less
than 10% of the tumors are character
characterized for use with targeted
therapy uh the tumors have activating
mutations in the rtk RAS raft pathway uh
with a handful of uh these mutations
recognized HFR the elk and Ross
rearrangements and B Raff and also when
the first line therapy fails the uh
resistant tumors tend to activate
alternate um genes in the cing pathway
in the RAS cing pathway the Met rat
Herby 2 and Tra and Ras
so how do these targeted therapy um
impact on patient outcome as you can see
here in the figure to the left we have
overall response rates and on the Y AIS
here we have response rate uh with
respect to targeted therapy and the lung
cancer lung aduno carcinomas and we can
see that initial uh treatment response
is very high um up to 80 90% of the
patients do response very well well
however on the right panel here we see
that progression free survival doesn't
change too much and most patients uh
progress have disease progressions
within two
years so that's one of the challenges of
therapy the other challenges of course
is that some of the cancers lack
alterations in the mitogen related
cyling genes most of the targeted
therapies are within this class
um of of uh biology inhibiting the
mitogen related cing genes here we show
that in the study be Kat Zang and team
they show that of the adenocarcinoma 33%
in the tcga cohort lack such alterations
instead these tumors have alterations in
the tumor suppressor genes as noted by
the Red Arrows to the left they also
have variants
um that are complex uh that changes the
structures um in terms of gains and
losses and at the moment we don't know
how these complex changes uh impact on
therapy and patient
outcome
so here we can see that traditionally
tumors um have been collected from
surgery biopsy
or fluids plural fluids aites or blood
and as we can see these are limited B
specimen and studies such as a tcj have
allow us to better understand the
underlying causes of tumor
aggressiveness however we need to
understand how it impacts on
function so how do we do this we would
try to collect tumor speciment from all
these um clinical Collections and try to
make the patient derive
models so here I'll just review quickly
that traditionally we've used human
cancer cell lines that are propagated
for a long time on plastic dishes now I
will be introducing the patient derived
models the xenographs and the organoid
models which hopefully will better
represent patient
tumors I'll quickly review the
advantages of the different types of
tumor models in the traditional T 2D
monol layer cells we have them growing
quite quickly uh within two or three
days doubling time um they're easy to
manipulate and that way they're very
cost effective and these cell lines have
been longtime study and extensive data
and experience have been gathered and we
have large collections of knowledge
through um these resources I've named
here the CCL the nci60 GD SC2 these are
data portals or collections of large
scale uh celline drug screening uh with
results and also portals where they uh
the pharmac codb and Synergy uh xdb were
try to collect all uh large scale drug
screening under one portal to be
searchable by variants and also the
genomic
profiling so the disadvantage of using
two 2D mon cultures is that they have
high selective pressure in the plastic
culture environment and they represent
um poorly the genetic diversity that we
see in
patients most importantly they are poor
predictors of patient
response compared to the PDX tumor
patient derived tumor xenographs these
mimic well the parent tumors they have a
tumor micro environment um representing
hypoxia acidity and they also have
better expent success rates for a wide
variety of tumor types compared to 2D
cultures of course the disadvantage of
that is that there's um operational
experiences needed um they are very slow
growing between two months per cycle
serial passaging to six months um
there's the mine stroma they last they
lack the immune uh component and also
they are difficult to genetically modify
the other models are the 3D Organo
models that are appearing in the last
few
years and I like to describe first the
patient derived organoid
models so we know that uh patient um the
organoid culture
method is uh refers to cell growing in a
3D in in vitro environment that can form
self-organizing structures of
differentiated cells the growth of
normal small cell intestine organoid at
self-organizing Crypts was first
described by in 2009 by Dr Hans
Cleaver's lab from which media was then
refined to establish the patient derived
tumor organoid that you see listed here
this is one of the um figures in his
review paper
and it lists some of the major uh tumor
types that's been established with the
highest success rates in pancreatic and
colon cancer models in the lung organoid
model um this project is run by uh Dr
Nikki radulovich and a former PhD uh
Kelly um Nikki is the living B Bank um
organoid manager and she she and her
team worked out the method uh refining
the medial culture from normal lung
cells to grow the patient derived tumor
organoids so Kelly and Nikki's team
receive collections of tumors from
resections or biopsies and the fragments
are dissociated enzymatically
dissociated and if they're from the
mouse the mouse uh cells are
depleted um the cells are resuspended in
The matrial Matrix and media is overlay
and the cells are grown within a couple
of weeks so Nikki lists here one two
three months um for two passages and if
they grow successfully it they will be
banked Crow preserved and viably blank
or else they'll be expanded for drug
screens using 384 Wells uh
method so the organoid um use and um
descriptions and applications of them
are described by Nikki previously in the
last year's um drug Discovery virtual
event series here I will describe some
of the updates and some of the more
recent uses with
PDX we can see here from the organoid
inventory that the major tumor types are
being represented we have um pancrea
ductal adinal carcinoma on lung uh small
cell esophageal ovarian and breast and
here the second column you can see the
uh different sources of tumor cells from
surgical biopsy and from the patient
derived xenographs tumors themselves and
we can see the breakdown of um how many
models have been successfully made and
you can see some features that Nikki's
team has recorded here that the organoid
models do vary in their success rate
um they have characteristics that we can
uh take note from the passage ratio
passage uh duration of the passages the
doubling rate and at the moment um Nikki
is collecting um the molecular profiling
data on these models to compare back to
the to the original tumor
sources and as you can see here on the
third rle the Nona lung cancer we can
see that most of the models made from
the PDX we can learn from the
experiences of the nonm salung cancer
that tick rate can also be dependent on
the source of the
tumors in terms of how we collect these
um clinical sources to make the models
here we can illustrate it through um the
workflow uh for the Taren kyes inhibitor
um timeline of the patient management
for lung cancer um whether they are
coming from the
original uh surgery or if they've come
onto for treatment of first line or
other lines of therapies um and disease
progresses and samples need to be taken
to further monitor disease and also
identify what other variants um are
evolving to cause resistance and
possibly put the patients on alternative
therapies we've worked in here um that
exus tissue from the tissue biopsy or
liquid biopsy used for Diagnostic be
used for the establishment of the
patient derived models we do try to
integrate the use of these models
together with clinical management
strategies for example if the testing of
the Next Generation sequencing panel
testing comes out and the PD drug screen
has been able to be followed adopt in
parallel then perhaps the two
information can be used to better um
direct patient care but often these
patient derived models have a timeline
that is much slower than the progression
of the disease of the patient themselves
so they tend to be used in preclinical
studies here I've summarized um the
inventory of our organoid models is near
240 models and increasing with the
collaboration of of our investigators at
The Institute to run their research
programs for the PDX models we have
close to 600 models uh core banked and
also uh new models being established
continuously from our clinical research
programs that I just described
previously and for the core banking to
occur we do follow a stringent method uh
of quality control checks for hystology
cancer markers DNA fingerprint to verify
with patient tumors pathogens panel
testing and also verify that that the
the models could be stably passage and
also um the characteristics are being
monitor for for um to verify that the
models are are robust for use and
experiments so here from our I'll move
forward to describe the PDX
methodology from our own work most and
some from other labs here represented we
can see that PDX is able to establish
for a range of tumor types the duid
denum the ovarian head and neck pancreas
lung and colon and here you can see a
range of the established success
rates and for the most part the um large
collections of the PDX have been able to
establish due to the availability of the
immunosuppress um Mouse used as the host
and here we can see in 1995 the not skit
variant is made available and so a lot
of the uh large collections has has
started to be established at this point
onwards at our Institute we've
interchangeably used the notot skid and
the NSG
which is a triple depletion of the t-
cells B cells and the natural color
cells for the solid tumor types we've
not seen a major difference between
either of these strains but perhaps if
you're doing stem cell Focus
um uh cell limiting dilution assays
where it's um very few cells being
injected um there is some differences
whereas the NSG uh would be preferred
strain to
use so here what are the determinants of
success for PDX um we learned this from
most obviously here from our HFR tumors
um publish reported by U Martins and
team and here we can see that for the
each of our mutants because they are
very poor at forming
engraftments um larger specimen therapy
resistant and met cesis um have a higher
OD ratio of engrafting as PDX
tumors taking a step back looking at all
the lung tumor types we can see that
engraftment on the top left panel we can
see that
engraftment uh predicts for much shorter
um disease-free survival in patients uh
compared to the non- engrafting
tumors and as a break break down from
the multivariate analysis here we can
see that scus uh Advanced stage and Eng
grabman are all independent factors
um for for poor disease free
survival in a closer look for the
cohorts that we do have representation
in terms of the different genotypes we
can see the each of our cohort are very
poor and grafters and that is reflected
also in the fact that P patients uh do
better in terms of outcome compared to
the K Ras mutant tumors you see at the
lower left panel here um engraftment is
fairly High um for kras mutants compared
to kras Wild type
tumors so a lot
of um these determinants of PDX
successes um are from studies that use
um tumors implanted at the subcutaneous
flank now I like to quickly um
acknowledge
that um we've describe that um from one
of our research Labs here in the lower
left panel um for the subcutaneous flank
method but we also have PDX um of other
methods for example the orthotopic
implant where tumors are implanted at
the uh original primary site or we can
have PDX that represents characteristics
of
metastasis uh functions and also PDX
that have a imuno humanized uh Mouse
component for uh drugging strategies
using immunotherapy so there are various
way to um establish
PDX for our purposes will focus on PDX
established in the subcutaneous um
pocket at the flank of the mouse here
you can appreciate the design where you
have a limited tumor fragment being
implanted into the first generation of
the mouse called peot Uh there's limited
tissue so we can only do one or two
mouse
implant once the tumors expand to a um
size of around 1.5 ctim we do harvest
the tumors and serly divide them and re
implant them to generate more tumor
resource more tumor specimens for
studies and for future research where we
CW Bank them CW inv viable tissues for
future research in terms of passaging of
tumors um in mice there are some quality
controls that one must be aware of
there's also the spontaneous lymphoma
outgrowth here shown in uh panel
designated number two to where you can
see tumor islands with the
pancytokeratin Positive cells uh in a
field of lymphoma outgrowth so in those
such cases we consider tumor model
failed also we review hystology for
potential bacteria or fungal
contaminants this can occur in oral
cancers as shown
here and those tumors um tend not to be
able to be propagated for long
time in terms of study design we can see
here that once the tumor is being
expanded um stably we can design a study
where groups of 1 to 12 mice uh are used
for drug testing where we have the first
group is a vehic group and then the
conditions one conditions two and so on
at our Institute we have standard
operating procedures and we use a study
lock Mouse database to acquire all of
our data and to manage and graph our
data so we use uh digital calipers that
reads directly into our database and
also digital
balance some of the features that one
can measure uh in terms of tumor growth
here you can see in the Y AIS is tumor
volume uh as estimated from the length
and width of tumor
measurements uh with the skin full and
here you can see over days typically
between 30 to 60 days growth to the
maximum size of around 1.5 cm in largest
diameter we you can appreciate that the
growth rates are um a little bit
different between the replicates and
thus we need the replicates to to um
monitor this variance here and the
effects of drug for example drug a where
we see uh slow down a growth uh growth
inhibition as a flatline growth here and
also the red line indicating some
cytotoxic effects here I would direct
you to a paper by Jessica Vice from our
team she's a destici staff um at our at
our team and she's consolidate over uh
44 studies uh representing over 25
unique models and 15 drugs and she
addresses the question questions of how
do we quantify response do we need to
increase number of replicates increase
the number of measurement and increase
the ration to reli reliably measure
response in our
studies so next I'm going to um lead you
to four different studies lead you
through four different studies of how we
use pedx and PDO
models here on the first study we're
using the PDF X model to show um ALK
inhibitor
resistance here I'll like to start with
panel number two here uh at
midpoint where we have a biopsy from a
patient in July
2016 and we uh initiated our PDX
protocol and we were able to establish
PDX and also the organoid derived from
the PDX for this model we did our first
drug screen because we didn't have the
two clinical drugs available yet uh the
elanip and the Lattin specific to out
Fusion uh
rearrangement we uh use a drug that is a
multikinase drug to Elk and met cottin
down in the low panel here directly
below you can see that there's the
vehicle uh treated group and also very
nice response uh tumor growth inhibition
in the cottin treatment
group um
this caused some excitement because uh
why as you can see from the clinical
timeline here the patient is resistant
and has progressed from the first uh
line of elk uh targeted therapy and so
the next line of out Target therapy is
latinate for tumors that are resistance
to altinate so we're surprised to see
some sensitivity here so Kelly backtrack
she's our former PhD student she
backtrack and she
retested um the PDX using the exact two
clinical therapies and as you can see
from the panel the growth panel to the
left um the two therapies are resistance
in the PDX so that tells us that the PDX
as is a reliable model to mimic patient
resistance and so we were curious since
the cottin is a multikinase inhibitor
the other Target would be met
amplification so we took the biopsy and
we retested for met amplification as you
can see highlighted yellow and yes we
did verify that the biopsy had met
amplification so as you can see here
even though clinically at that time um
they were only doing single Gene testing
um as you know now um when tumors
progress patients are um being biopsy
when possible and test it with Next
Generation sequencing for a whole panel
of possible um actionable genes and also
known resistant mechanis mechanisms that
could be
targeted so in the next study I like to
show you uh work done by Josh Rosen our
current PhD
student in our lab and he's here trying
to see if um potential therapies for
kras mutant um do they have the same
effect across all kras uh mutant
subtypes as you can see here um he has a
few models uh with the subtypes of g12d
g12c g12v and G
g13c and here in panel figure
3B uh Josh did a used the pedia to do
the drug screen for the drug salor which
inhibits a nuclear expert protein
exportin and is thought to be um kras
mutant is thought to be sensitive to
this drug and he compared it with um
another drug Poss inhibiting the same
pathway the RT K Ras raft pathway and he
wanted to see if the two drugs had the
same effect since potentially they're
inhibiting the same pathway here you can
see that through um linear mix modeling
effect um looking at the individual
Mouse growth um Josh has modeled the
effects of the vehicle and shown
effectiveness of the two drugs of Select
Celexa nexor and ttin and here we can
see that when comparing um drug
inhibition with the vehicle control
group um that both drugs uh inhibit
tumor growth quite well across the
models and he asked a question does the
uh specific subtypes of the kras
mutation have an effect and for models
that have enough
representation um we were able to to do
this test and here you can see that
there's no uh selectivity in the k
subtype for drug sensitivity however
when Josh looked at the
tp53 background of these tumors it seems
that p-53 mutant models together with
kras um can result in less sensitivity
to drug so as we know there are more
drugs available um for the kasas mutants
tumor and because the testing using PDX
is very timec consuming and could take
up close to a year to screen up to 10
models uh Josh went on to make uh
xenograph derived
organoids and he showed this in one of
his drug screens using specific
inhibitor for the kras
g12c uh how do we show that these drugs
are selected for g12c
We compare them to other types or the
wild type of K Ras and here Josh shows
that with the Xeno xenograph derived uh
organoid models we're able to show that
the kras g12c the green lines are more
sensitive to the inhibitor than the kras
wild type
models and here it's they're shown in
their um the dose range uh that they
were testing On and Here in the right
panel by their ic50 you can see that
most of the mutants are being inhibited
except there's one model that is
resistant and as for the kras wild type
models there's a range of
sensitivity so the interesting um
question is here is what is the
underlying cause of tumor
heterogenity and this is also observed
at the clinical level and it and Josh is
going going moving forward to um analyze
these models um not only at the um
genotype level but at the transcriptomic
and also the proteomic and the phosphor
proteomic level to see if there are
other features that we can pick up to
predict for tumor
sensitivity in the next uh study that I
like 2.2 is the use of PDX to uh model
drug tolerant persistent cells um this
is a phase where cells can adapt to
targeted therapy before they become
resistance here you can see the panel to
the left we have a model with the
typical activating each of our mutation
and it's very sensitive we have the
vehicle control arm
growing and then we have the treatment
on the first generation tyzine kise
inhibitor selective for the HFR mutant
and we can see here that the tumor
actually become almost nonpalpable
during this phase of drug tolerant
persister and how do we know that they
are drug tolerant is because once um we
have we give them a drug holiday as you
can see here with this uh starting the
initial growth once the drug holiday is
lifted in the open circle uh there are
viable cells and those cells do grow up
and behave like the original tumor so so
Erin our former graduate student um did
some hystology and realized that in the
drug tolerant persistor phase um this
environment is a stromal rich
environment and she further investigated
to take sampling at different time
points during this phase um to do single
cell RNA
sequencing so what do we learn from that
uh we learned that in terms of the
exomic mutations that the drug drug
tolerant persistor phase is very similar
to Baseline phase and here from the RNA
seek analysis um the results are shown
as titney splots in which uh each dot is
a cells and cells are placed nearby one
another if they have similar
transcriptomic profiles um here you can
see um the dots being placed um as a
whole population and we have the 137
Baseline colored in red and the drug
tolerant persist phase color in blue and
we can see that in panel a there are
clusters um concentrated in one cluster
in panel B you can see that this cluster
we termed it number
six is a is is is a group of cells that
in uh Pano D you can say that they are
quiescent this was not surprising
but uh we are in the process of looking
at the um expression changes and and
mapping the enriched Pathways to
determine what signaling Pathways is
involved in maintaining this drug
tolerant persistor
phase we also realize that um the mirin
dramaa is looking different between um
the Baseline and the drug tolerant
persistor phase remember before I was
mentioning that um one of the
disadvantages of PDX is the mirin stroma
but in looking at the mirin stroma here
um we may glean some useful
information that the stroo um the cancer
Associated fiolas stroma um can also be
influen uh or probably U May influence
uh drug tolerant persistor cells here we
can identify um the the drug torrent
persistent stroma
clustering together compared to the
Baseline uh stroma and Roya went on to
um elucidate what was happening uh in
these
population between the Baseline and the
drug tolerant phase uh Roy has
elucidated some of the factors that
could be secreted uh the different
factors to maintain proliferation at
Baseline phase and also the factors that
can help with self survival during drug
tolerant phase and this has been
reported in paper by mogal and team
recently another
um uh another result from our our our
lung pedx um studies is also what I've
shown before is uh using uh mutations
and
transcriptomic um um to identify
underlying causes of drug response and
Drug resistance here I will show that um
we have new data using um proteum uh
profiling by
TMT U Mass spectrometry and here um we
have a paper that classify our
xenographs with respect to the protal
types um as we can see here in panel a
uh the prote type ID identified by the
um groups shown in blue the lung adinal
carcinoma group one two and three and as
you go down the the rows here um we have
stage being identified uh various
clinical features and also the
transcriptomic uh classical subtypes and
the methylome subtypes and we can see
that the prototypes actually identify a
totally different group of of um
grouping of tumors that are different
from transcriptome predictions and
methylome
predictions and that the protot types in
panel C here you can see that uh group
one two and three have different uh
overall survival for the patients uh
group three being the most aggressive in
the green line with the shortest um
overall
survival um this is reflected in that it
is representing tumor stages that are
higher in the panel e below here you can
see that in group one group two uh all
stages of lung cancer are represented
but in group three that is lost um
what's also interesting is that um
different altered uh genes are being
enrich in the different groups uh group
one having the best survival uh has the
clust has the enrichment of the each of
our mutants followed by group two with
the various um variants and group
three interestingly um what do these
prototypes tell in terms of drug
response we had an independent study
that um with having the prototypes
helped us to uh understand better why
there was drug response we had a model
uh called PHL C
134 and we did a panarin kyes drug
screen and here in panel D you can see
some
effect and it responded really well to
each of our kise inhibitor and we were
curious as to why because it didn't have
the activated mutations here you can see
that um from the genomics we see that
efrs amplify and from the mpect um
analysis of the proteins total protein
uh was much higher uh compared to any
other lung adal carcinoma as you can see
here plotted and in the panel below we
can see the HFR tiring phosphor tiing
sites here that is being activated um
perhaps this is a feature um that has
resulted in drug sensitivity but we know
that in clinic um each of our
amplification
um is not a reliable feature for
targeted therapy uh as you can see here
it may have depended on um protein being
expressed that we see in this model so
I've hope to um describe all these four
scenarios to you to show that PDX um and
PDO modeling can help us better
understand some of the uh cancer
treatment challenges
I will move on to um emphasize that for
these models to be a renewable resources
and to be available for researchers to
use um they they must be organized um in
a in a living B Bank
format um because here you can see that
there are a lot of operational um
efforts involved in terms of the
establishment of the models and also um
the B banking which is supported by
standard bile Banks um for the tissue
itself but for the these patient derived
organoid models they rely heavily on the
accumulated data for the Proto genomics
and also the clinical data that needs to
be curated for proper use of these
models and proper um uh studies to be
performed depending on uh what phase of
the patient clinical management they
were collected from um so I would like
to so I would like to uh emphasize that
data is an important feature for um for
living B bank and um for the use of
these patient derived models as you can
see here at our Institute we are
supported by the data science group um
to help upload all the genomics and the
proteon data into our own institutional
Cal portal
doca database and here you can
appreciate um here we have all the
xenographs that have been profile
including our latest addition of the
organoid models and all these studies
can be integrated and analyzed together
and here I've just put a simple uh
representation of some of the genes
across
um our adenocarcinoma models and you can
appreciate that you can overlay the
different um DNA RNA and protein
alterations and see perhaps what is the
truly underlying cause um of of of the
phenotypic um drug
response also I like to emphasize all
the data um that is collected during
model establishment
um which is typically not um being
collected by by any data portals or by
standard cancer banking uh of tissues uh
we have our QC data DNA fingerprinting
data that our Institute has built a
customized portal for us to uh to upload
all the data uh associated with our
models to verify them with the patient
tumors and we're still working on um
using existing data portals or
customizing our own to keep other types
of data that are very important for um
for experiments um and the design of the
experiments and for QC process that's
just the pathogens uh database that we
have to
monitor in terms of making the models
available to researchers and also
combining our efforts as you can see
from the uh four results once you get
down from um classifying the tumors as
driver genes if you go further and
classify them by
commutations um the
representations of uh that particular
genotype for study becomes very small uh
we're dilling down to about three or
four models of similar characteristics
to test and study so how do we combine
our resources to do that um we have some
of the online portals right now we have
the cancer models uh portal uh supported
by NCI the europ PDX and also um some
commercial vendors where um all the
researchers upload the models up to this
portal for visualization and um users um
can email directly the model
contributors uh to access the models and
from the cancer models of course you can
go directly to the different um programs
um that are bi banking PDX and pdos for
example the NCI which is the patient
derived model repository we have the
Euro PDX
Consortium and also uh relatively new is
the organoid arm from the human C Atlas
uh
portal just to give you an idea um um on
the patient models
portal we have about 27 Labs uh they
have 27 Labs represented uh in terms of
contributing data to this portal and uh
the models can be searched by genotype
tumor type treatment type uh and various
other features um here I've simply
listed uh the labs and we the Princess
Margaret living B bank is a part of this
um
portal most of our published models are
listed here as you can see and I I think
this is a a very good way forward for um
for for doing for having these models
available to researchers and for um
progressing uh towards studies that are
in uh of interest to Precision medicine
because of each of these tumors are
truly unique uh when we get down to the
the variants that classify
them um I like to reemphasize here that
there is uh considerable effort in the
um establishment of the models
themselves um the technical expertise
and the tumor type specific methods um
in the second box there is also another
big jump and effort another big effort
for The annotation of the model the
clinical pathological annot ation as
well as the molecular and proteome
annotation and then of course last um is
the fun part once uh the models is
established and annotated we can design
the experiments to address hopefully the
uh clinical relevant um studies uh to
improve patient
outcome so some of the take-home
messages uh on patient devive models
here is that we need more models mod we
need more models to represent the tumor
diversity um we need to continue to
evaluate these models uh for Fidelity
towards the original tumors and how well
they continue to um behave like the
original tumors in terms of drug
response um we also need to uh profile
these tumors that goes beyond uh
standard biobanking and uh Next
Generation biobanking uh also has to
support in the data Resource
Management um so hopefully once the
models are made we can use these models
to obviously um identify potential new
cancer biomarkers and identify
vulnerabilities um in the resistance of
treatment or uh novel drug classes um to
improve patient
outcome so um to end my presentation i'
like to acknowledge the living B Bank
team made up of the model contributors
and the scientists um that has the
research program to integrate the
establishment of these models um
recognize the Organo team run by Nikki
radulovich and also we couldn't have
accelerated so fast in our living B bank
without the support of our um Uhn cores
uh or other research cores um that's you
know helped us with the um Animal
Facility the B banking procedures um the
hiso bomark lab and also the data uh
components of running such a program and
I'd like to uh thank our fundings of the
Princess Margaret Cancer Foundation and
the Ontario research fund uh and we also
like to acknowledge the uh cancer
associations uh which the pis have um
receive funds from the cihr and our
Canan Cancer Society so with that note
uh I'd be happy uh to receive um
comments and questions and I will
address them in the emails thank
you